in like in the commentary community. I thought it'd be unanimously,
you know,
>> Oh my god. Oh my god. Charlie saying it. Charlie's saying
it. Skulls CPS. Skulls CPS. Skulls CPS. Skulls. CPS. CPS. Skulls.
CPS. Skulls. CPS. Skulls. Embarrassing. Shameful. You are shameful.
The dragon is right. The dragon was correct. The dragon was totally
correct.
I think we're ready to move into the Ethan Klein stuff. Now,
we'll start off, guys, if you have not caught this story. Obviously,
Ethan Klein Idubbbz streamed two days ago, I believe, to let
us know that he was getting sued by Ethan Klein. Here's the video
real quick. >> It is official.
I am being sued by Ethan Klein
in the courts of Calgary, Alberta
for defamation. >> Oh my god.
I do plan on fighting against this, but for now it is in the
hands of the courts. We go from there. I'm going to start with
the Ethan Klein stream from yesterday. The one I didn't get a
chance to get to yesterday cuz we didn't stream. All right, we're
going to start with this guy and then we're going to work our
way out from there. >> So, this is Ethan Klein commenting
on this before
before the moist critical video. Okay, the most critical video
is of course going to be centered in our conversation today,
but this is before that actually came out.
Basically, I feel like most people that watch this show understand
and in this community, but I've seen like, for example, um Moist
Critical sent Harley a DM being like, "Yo, this is super What's
up? What's up, Harley?" >> Damn you. >> Wait, he
did? >> Yeah. He goes, "What's up, Harley? I heard I heard
about Ethan's new lawsuit, and it's about as concerning as finding
a war on the bottom of my ball sack." So, this is where we knew
that there was going to maybe be a Moist critical video was Ethan
Klein comes out and basically makes it clear that Harley got
reached out to by Moist and we don't like Moist. We're not fans.
>> I don't know. So, this is for people online who haven't
heard me talk about it before. So, yes, I'm suing my uh
>> my former bestie Idubbbz who um and I'll just I'll shortly
explain why because it to me it kind of doesn't it's not that
big of a mystery. Um, as you may or may not know, um, Ian has
deeply aligned himself with the Snark community that is, um,
>> responsible for and celebrated CPS coming to my house
to take my children
>> He's deeply aligned with the Snark community. How How
did he get deeply aligned with the Snark community in this >> And
sending human skulls to my home. These are two things that on
on the Snark Discord they have on the banner. They have a skull
with
Does Does Ethan know that the Snark Discord is like not even
remotely
like there's almost no real tangible connection to the actual
H3 Snark group that like was made after that with a community
of people that was like known and not a part of those communities?
Does he understand that at all or did somebody like lie to him
and pretend that these communities are like strongly like tightly
coupled and connected?
I would just wonder because if he was if he was freaking out
on Idubbbz and he was blaming Idubbbz for a bunch of stuff and
somebody lied to him and said that these communities are like
the same and it's all it's all connected other than there's a
bunch of people out there who basically don't like the idea that
you can call something snark and make it evil and that you're
going to try to trample on critics and stuff. They don't like
that. So, we have a logo that is Yeah. skull with CPS on it carved
into it. I don't know.
>> With CPS on the forehead. They think it's funny. They
love it. They're proud of it. And um Idubbbz aligns with them,
shouts them out, calls them great people. He's browses the subreddit
on his live stream. He's in deep with them. In fact,
even in um his follow-up to his content cop, he he justified
it. He says, "I think it's good that uh CPS was called and investigated
that because um clearly as someone who's been to Ethan's house
and met his children, um there's all over the place and his kids
are clearly in um trouble and would be in better care of foster
would be in would be better taken care of in foster care."
>> Do we think that Idubbbz said all of that? Do we do
we think Idubbbz said all of that, guys? So, of course, Ethan
having made so many enemies over the years, other people react
to his content. And when other people see that he's talking about
uh his children getting giardia from dog poop, >> uh Sunny's
crawling around. He's putting everything in his mouth. He's at
that age. He has giardia. >> People are quite reasonably
concerned. And so, yes, anyone who's seeing that content might
be concerned enough to call CPS, including Ethan's own chat,
which by the way is not a measly number. It's about 26,000 at
the time of this >> So, there is no justification yet.
There's an explanation of why Ethan is like risking himself and
his family safety by talking about this stuff. Now, what Ethan
does instead of taking any responsibility for sharing too much
on his live stream is that he decides to attack specific creators
like Denims and say she was the source of the CPS call because
her chat was reacting to Ethan and saying, "Wow, this is concerning
is >> So, still I've not heard any I've not Oh, hold on.
Ethan is attempting to smear Denims who does not condone CPS
call. Wow. Literally at no point there does he ever say that
you deserve to have CPS called on you. He says you have some
culpability here and you you dole out zero culpability to yourself
cuz you are a loser. Right.
That's all he said. So Ethan Klein massively self victimizing
on his
Anyway, following all that, Ian went on his stream and uh displayed
this message. So it says so he's blowing this up and he does
aren't >> confused a um >> he does it as a watermark
for his whole hours long stream. First of all, this is a comment
from Destiny like made in passing. Ian put it on his screen for
two hours during his main broadcast.
Destiny said it again after this. Destiny said this to you multiple
times. Destiny's called Ethan Klein multiple times. And really
the the big difference here, okay, the big difference all of
this stuff, the really big difference here is
like I'd said he didn't even believe it. Die and Ethan both call
people all the time. It's like something they do
I don't know why. How many times did this guy call Dan Clansancy
an actual
made it clear that he was not being serious, right? Um pretty
much immediately after writing it. Like
immediately after writing it. I don't Yeah, I don't know. I don't
think that's true either.
>> Don't see how you can say that I'm not justified when
somebody's who's your former friend who's been your house to
make your children is broadcasting this as a silly just to oh,
it's just silly. Ethan needs to address this little minor claim
that he his own children and he's
>> um is that funny? I don't know. Is that a joke? Is that
free speech? I don't think so.
He's saying you're a who got slapped by Destiny so you let Destiny
say anything about you.
Which by the way, how could that be defamation? That is fact.
That is just fact.
You are too much of a to do anything to Destiny. You got punked
by him and you are too much of a to ever step to him again. And
so you're going after Idubbbz. That is just fact. That's what
Idubbbz was saying. I I'm just I totally fail to understand why
people are finding the need to take this principal stance in
favor of fair use when I'm when my complaint is that he said
I my children. It's not like he called me an [__]
or a meme head or whatever the you know. >> Again, he didn't
say that.
Again, he he just didn't say that. So, it's Ethan Klein just
perpetually lying to his audience. Do I need the dicker tweet
one more time? One more time
for those in the back. Now, there is one thing to the dicker
tweet, right? I keep saying it's the dicker. It's this clip right
here. There is one thing. >> Okay. So, I do want to say
I don't agree with what's being said in this um comment here.
Uh, but I I'm putting it on screen because I think it should
be addressed because it's a big bold accusation that's very up.
Now, the up thing here is that I believe this is after like months
and months of Ethan's community of Kino Casino of these people
all tearing apart every aspect of Ana and Ian's content and lives
to make fun of them, right? which by the way I usually support.
But
why
why when this guy finally starts to fight back in any way you
have to sue him immediately? Like you guys are all going after
him. You're all laughing. You're all making fun of him and he
fights back even a tiny bit and you have to you have to go to
court instantly.
That's so unbelievably
Anyway, on to Charlie's video on H3 versus Zidubbs the lawsuit.
I did spend like the last three hours learning about this defamation
lawsuit between H3 and Idubbbz because that did sound pretty
concerning. Let's go. Because there's always been like an unwritten
rule on the internet, not just YouTube, where if there's beef
online, it stays online and you handle it online without, you
know, going over that threshold, the event horizon of trying
to use litigation to silence your opponent or something like
that. That had always been etched in the stone tablets, the Ten
Commandments of online discourse. And now all of a sudden I'm
hearing about H3 suing Idubbbz for defamation. So obviously I
wanted to hear more about that. And after diving in hitting that
cannonball into the pool, I learned he has a lot of active lawsuits.
I think it's five maybe six against other streamers and
So it's it it's a bit of a rampage he's been on. I knew about
one before all this which was against the snark community that
I did hear about and that one made a lot of sense to me actually.
The snark community from what I recall was doing some diabolical
like harassing, stalking stuff that sending CPS. I remember remember
that and like human skulls. Those things I recalled from like
the snark community. So it made sense that he would pursue litigation
there cuz that is highly illegal
psychopath behavior.
So that one I remember and that one made sense to me. But when
I was learning about these other ones, I granted I haven't dove
too deep into all those because this is clearly a lot. I was
mainly focused on the defamation one, but
highly illegal. Well, I mean, the CPS call would be illegal.
The the skulls might be illegal under like some sort of menacing
law or something. The the CPS call is a false CPS call. It is
illegal,
right? Assuming they put some false information in there, >> man.
Ethan I would say also the crazy thing to me is
is I don't know did they I'm expecting there to be a police report
that gets publicized at some point. They should have filed the
police report, right? It's a false if it's a false filing of
a of like a CPS claim, there should be it should be handed off
to the police at some point. >> Clearly a lot. I was mainly
focused on the defamation one, but man, Ethan Klein has become
like the Nintendo of YouTubers. He is extraordinarily latgious.
Anyway, enough blabbering. What started this Ah, Nintendo. Nintendo.
Ah,
the Nintendo of YouTubers. Yes, I see what you're saying, Charlie.
He's like, "The Nintendoation
lawsuit was this Idubbbz stream." >> Okay, this is my watermark
for the the
>> I don't want any of my content being
Got another cowi ad. I'm sorry, Fazium. We're all getting cowi
ads these days.
It's okay. So, I do want to say I don't agree with what's being
said in this um comment here.
Uh but I I'm putting it on screen because I think it should be
addressed because it's a big bold accusation that's very up.
>> It is very up and it's despicable that he would think
it's a good idea to post that there while knowingly aware that
it's not true. So the >> you have no reason to believe
it's true, but that's that's pedantic.
am I crazy? I do feel like does moist is he missing the context
of like basically these people going after him for like quite
a long time like people around those communities,
right, of Ethan like basically saying, "I'm going to harass you.
I'm going to I'm going to follow you around everywhere for like
the rest of your life on the internet." Is he aware of any of
this? Cuz to be honest, I think that is a little important that
he's like trying to figure out how to operate in a world that
he's not used to. You know what I mean? I And I'm not saying
that Idubbbz should be able to like break the law because of
that or that he should be able to do whatever he wants because
of that. I'm saying that there's a reason it's gotten to that
level of rhetoric where he's going to put that comment on screen
to with Ethan. There's a reason it got there, right? And it's
not entirely on him. It's a cycle that's going back and forth
that's continuously escalating.
So, it's not like an excuse. It's just a description. So, he's
saying, "Well, it's it's so disgusting." It's like, "Well, I
don't know. I think Ethan implied that Ana was a groomer, right?"
So, that's just where it was, man. That's just where that's that's
just where that discourse got to, I guess. >> Message isn't
Ian's. This comes from Destiny. And he found this screenshot
and he kept it on screen for a very long time. and he said he
didn't agree with it but thinks it needs to be addressed because
it's soed up. It is a terrible stream. Just giving it to you
real blunt, real raw. It is no good.
And I'm no stranger to getting talked by Idubbbz. He has said
some very nasty, very untrue things about me on his broadcast
as well. But what is being reported in regards to this stream
isn't exactly telling the whole story. Now, when I first heard
of this lawsuit, I was reading a bunch about it, but
oh my god.
Now, I want to point out something that's very cool. I'm going
to actually go back to believing that Charlie is not online at
all, cuz I do believe that within like 2 to 3 hours of any amount
of unbiased reading, you would come to the same conclusion. Everybody
who doesn't come to that conclusion is quite literally brainwashed
into believing anything else like some other solution or some
other reason for this. Right. I'm So I'm back to I do believe
within two to three hours of looking into things, you could figure
out, oh, Ethan Klein's just lying.
Ethan Klein's just lying about why this is filed, how this what
what the purpose is, he's lying about everything.
Yep.
>> Oh my god. Am I going to like a Charlie video? But I
wanted more information like directly associated with it to make
sure I wasn't getting like fraudulent or misleading fed to me.
So I reached out to someone whom I know is on the H3 team. And
I fully understand that this is a very emotionally charged subject
for him after everything him and his family have went through
with snarkers in particular. I know that the
I which I wonder which level of lie or which level of like distortion
Charlie's at. It sounds like he's still in some pretty old ones.
The the Hassan and Ethan debate one where it's Oh, Starker's
called CPS.
We We still don't know
ultimately. And there are multiple suspects, multiple people
it could be who called CPS on
And ultimately, if there was never any police investigation initiated,
I assume that's because he doesn't think it's snarkers and wants
to blame them. To be honest with you, >> PS and the human
skulls incident are like a legitimately traumatizing thing. like
the fraudulent CPS call. Like I I get how inexcusable and abhorrent
that is. I really do. But I just truly don't believe that this
lawsuit is in any way, shape, or form helpful to anyone outside
of the lawyers. They're smiling ear to ear. They're salivating
right now. Literally drooling with a bib on. But it's harmful.
>> And again, Idubbbz had not said anything when CPS was
called to Ethan. Like right right when CPS was called on Ethan
and his family, Idubbbz had not said anything. Idubbbz had not
said how are we blaming Idubbbz for this.
Well, I know how he's blaming him. He's saying well afterwards
he associated with people who who were like somewhat culpable
is what Ethan would have you believe. But I what? Who? Where?
He likes some tweets.
Apparently liking some tweets is now enough to be like, "Well,
I'm going to sue you and try to ruin your life. I want I want
you at a house at home because you like some >> I I just
can't see the real just cause behind it. And I think it is a
terrible example for other creators in the space to follow where
maybe they believe that even though this is about like a Canadian
defamation lawsuit, well, maybe they can try their luck in the
States. You know, it's not like defamatory lawsuits are exclusive
to Canada. There's better protections here, no doubt. But still,
if they take from this that maybe the way to fight battles online
is to go the latigious route, well then it's just a huge mess
across the board. I think it is just a very bad precedent. Even
if you know the lawsuit doesn't end in a victory for him, this
way of engaging with discourse, I think has always been frowned
upon. But for
>> he doesn't even need to win the lawsuit to win. That's
the sad thing.
Like that's the other thing about this. And I I'm guessing Charlie
reached out to Ethan fairly early on. And I'm guessing he doesn't
get fully honest answers, but I don't believe there's even really
a claim from Ethan's side that he thinks that he's like really
in the right here and that this this had to be done. And
like worst of all, I don't even know if there's really a claim
from Ethan's side that they're going to win, that they think
they can win. He has said explicitly, no matter what, it's going
to cost them so much in lawyer fees it's going to ruin them.
That's what they're saying, right? That's what I keep hearing
from everybody. It doesn't even matter if they win. They're going
to they're going to destroy them. They're going to destroy them
with lawyers fees. So, the goal isn't even to win. It's not about
whether or not it's like a feasible lawsuit. It's just I'm gonna
spend money to ruin your life. >> Some reason is starting
to get some more support behind it. And I just fully disagree
with it. I think that this is genuinely just a like big threat
across the board to just the entire space. Like if discourse
becomes, you know, fearful of like litigation flying back and
forth, it's going to stifle a lot of voices and stifle some very
like legitimate criticism down the line. It's just not something
I want to see become common place. Now, I did also have a brief
conversation with Idubbbz about this as well, letting him know
that this really is a horrible thing that he did to try and make
his point, and he agreed. He said that it was a legitimately
awful thing that he did to make that point and that it was a
genuine, sincere apology that he was issuing and how regretful
he was from it. I don't know how it works in Canada if the complaint
is public or what,
>> but if you look at it, he um emphasizes throughout that
he does think it's a serious accusation that needs to be investigated
and that he doesn't think it's a joke, right? Destiny made it
clear that he was not being serious, >> Not very quickly,
>> pretty much immediately after writing it. Like nobody
was like, "Yo, Destiny made this claim that Ethan his children.
Oh shit." No, people knew that when Destiny said it, it was like
in it was he was just being a [__] or I mean he was
being a giant piece of [__] right? But he immediately
afterwards made it clear that he didn't actually think that.
>> Now, after hearing Ethan explain that, I actually made
the noble sacrifice of going back and watching the entire Idubbbz
stream segment with this in it when he was talking about it.
Boy, howdy.
I'm not a hero. It was brave, but I don't need your flowers.
That was agonizing. It was heinous even. It was brutal. This
whole segment where he was talking about that I think was really,
really rough. But I don't recall at any point throughout it him
actually trying to argue that it's a legitimate thing or trying
to convince his audience that it's real. So I know one of the
big things is that it came from Idubbbz who has actually met
Ethan and his family. So there's like this air of credibility
around him saying something. >> So that's the big thing
that Charlie's laying out right here. And the obvious thing that
makes Ethan Klein a degenerate liar again. He is full of He's
full of baloney. He cannot. He is incapable of telling a truth.
Okay,
Idubbbz did not try to convince people that this happened. Idubbbz
was not going, "Oh, no, no, no. This is a thing that needs to
be looked into because I'm concerned for those kids." He didn't
do that. That never happened. That's just a lie. Ethan keeps
saying like this, keeps lying about it over and over and over
again. No, wrong >> thing like this. But that's just not
true. He's not even trying to say anything about it is credible.
Even outright says that it's not that he doesn't agree with it.
So, he's not trying to present it as a real argument based on,
you know, any of his experiences knowing Ethan and his >> Also,
I do I will say that I think Ethan Klein is uh terrified of this
guy. So, it just kind of like legit it's it is to me it's super
funny
uh that uh he he has so much smoke for everyone that he thinks
he can bully, but the person that he's terrified he just keeps
very overtly running from. And it's like, >> Now, while
Ethan is 100% correct that Idubbbz says that this is a big allegation
that Ethan should be addressing, he's not doing it earnestly,
or at least I don't think he was. It's actually really kind of
hard to tell. The whole segment was awful. And >> it's
not hard to tell at all. Stop. Why does he have to do this weird
hand ringing? The segment was really bad. It was like really
gross. And I didn't like it. It was maybe a little hard to tell.
No, it wasn't. It's literally not hard to tell at all. It's perfectly
obvious, Charlie. It's completely obvious what's going on there.
Whatever. >> The point he was trying to make was really
done. But what he's trying to say is that clip right there at
the end where Destiny said this extremely outrageous, outlandish,
disgusting thing about Ethan and yet Ethan doesn't have smoke
for him, but he does for the other people that he's gone after
through lawsuits. I'm pretty sure that's the point he was trying
to make by putting that on screen. Like, look, Destiny has said
something absolutely despicable, yet you >> He said something
despicable. Destiny has explicitly called for CPS to be called
on Ethan Klein.
The two things that he said made him go nuts and he needs to
save his family from these people. Destiny also got up and walked
away during his reaction to the content nuke. He did not transform
it anywhere near what Denims did. He didn't even transform it
to the level Asmin Gold did.
Ethan Klein for his pre from his previous pattern has every
every piece in place to go and defend his family in the way he's
laid up before.
Why is he not Hello? Can anybody I anybody who's still defending
this guy just explain to me given he all the things he said he
believes. How do you even make sense of that? How could you possibly
make sense of that? It makes no
You don't have that same energy for him as you do for for the
others. Unless I've blanked out and like erased moments from
my memory from this segment. I don't recall him saying saying
that this is like a serious thing he believes in is and is presenting
it as such like about Ethan is this and this is a real allegation
that really has a lot of water to it. Now this doesn't change
the fact that what Idubbbz did here is completely awful to try
and make this point using that kind of comment with something
as monstrously evil as that is just so low. It is but I don't
believe it's how Ethan is necessary.
Okay. Now, if let's say we agreed that it is so low, what would
you say about Ethan Klein totally ignoring the person who actually
made the comment,
right? It is so low. It's so It's so low to make that to amplify
that comment because you're having a fight with somebody. That's
disgusting. Well, what do we think about the person who made
the comment in the first place? Uh, >> has anybody asked
about that? What's going on? >> Explaining it to everyone
where Idubbbz is really, you know, believing in this. you know,
Idubbbz came over to my house, he met my family, now he's going
out there saying these things. It is extremely scummy because
he did meet his kids and everything. And now he's putting a comment
out there like that. That is very scummy. But he's not using
it to try and make this claim that Ethan is those things. He's
trying
Well, while I agree and Charlie's going about this the right
way. I actually like that Charlie's approaching it this way.
As much as it annoys me, I like that it's being approached this
way because he's still giving Ethan Klein a bunch of the benefit
of the doubt that I can't give him anymore. like he's giving
Ethan Klein a ton of benefit of the doubt. He is treating Ethan
like he is still the main victim here. Like he has been victimized
in a way nobody could possibly comprehend.
And while I agree he has been hurt by this whole thing, I don't
treat him like the victim when he is the one doing all of the
harm anymore. Right? Like basically nobody else is doing anywhere
near the harm Ethan is and we're going to keep treating him like
a victim. It's to me. But it's good that Charlie's doing it because
it will actually hit for some people. You know what I mean? I
hate it. But for some other people, that's what they need to
hear. They need to hear somebody like give him all of this charity
so they can get pulled out of the the matrix. Okay. >> Trying
to use that to show that Destiny has said something so terrible,
yet you are not approaching him with the same energy you have
everybody else. That is the point he was trying to make, I think,
throughout that segment, at least from everything that I saw
when watching it. Granted, it was very hard to sit through, but
I'm pretty sure that's what he was trying to get at with that
there. But I think that was a terrible way of going about it.
Now, Ethan also addresses why he's not suing Destiny as well.
And he's saying because Destiny cleared up that he wasn't being
serious right away. I don't understand. >> That's not true,
man. That's that's just not true. And it's not even about it
being serious or not serious. Destiny said it. I think knowing
it was false to hurt Ethan Klein. Like that is another way to
look at this. You have actual malice in the statement you're
making
and you say, "No, I I'm literally just saying it to this person
because they were mean to me, right?" Very different. >> Understand
that. I'm not going to lie. That's not making sense to me. Can't
wrap my noodle around it. It's not computing. I think it is a
very disgusting statement. 100%. He's not wrong for feeling like
this is a terrible thing that's being said about him. That is
a line you don't cross talking about people's children in a manner
like this. It's gross. It is gross. So then why is this defamation
lawsuit reserved exclusively for Idubbbz with a nice big bow
on it but not also extended to Destiny the genesis of that comment?
Does that not just prove the point that I believe Idubbbz was
trying to make in the first place which is Destiny for some reason
can say these atrocious abhorrent
does it does totally prove that as cringe as you may have found
that segment the dragon is right. The dragon was correct. The
dragon was totally correct things about Ethan and for some reason
Ethan doesn't have the same anger towards Destiny as he does
someone like Idubbbz. Now I guess with Idubbbz you could then
say well Idubbbz actually did meet his children and stuff so
it's an extra level of up which is fair. I do completely agree.
It does add another up rancid layer to this lasagna here where
he did actually know Ethan and his family and would use a a comment
like that to try and make his statement about like being soft
on Destiny or whatever. But I still just don't understand why
Ethan is willing to just be like, "Yeah, but Destiny, you know,
cleared up that he wasn't being serious. He was just goofing
around. He was just being a dickhead."
What if the reason truly is that Canada's laws around defamation?
Oh, wait. Also,
if Destiny was just joking
Oh, no. Probably doesn't work. I
I'm trying to think of like how you still sue Idubbbz. Yeah,
I just don't get it. Realistically, it's probably not even the
thing anymore for Ethan. I do think that
Dan, Destiny, Ethan, just clearly on the same side of like a
larger internet battle against like 50 people, by the way. But
clearly on the other side of a larger internet battle they're
trying to do here. You know what I mean?
And I think that's the reason he's not suing him is they've just
decided, well, actually, we got to
the I think they think they're losing again in their attempt
to take down Hassan is truly what I think it is. I think they
see that they're losing. They they they feel like they're not
taking Hassan down. They're not doing enough there. And they
have to join forces because if they work against each other,
well, they're
I don't think Ethan really even I don't think he believes Destiny
was like doing this as a joke or in a way that he said he was
kidding about. I don't think any of that's true. I think Ethan
is just like, "No, no, no. We need to align against the greater
evil, okay,
the true threat to Israel, okay? >> Are significantly more
lax and thus you have a case in Canada but not the US, then to
me that tells me that it's not really a defamation case worth
pursuing." And if you're not going after Destiny for these comments,
but you will for Idubbbz trying to make a different point about
it. Again, I want to make it clear. I think the way Idubbbz went
about doing this point is atrocious. I don't know how much more
clear I can make. But he wasn't trying to argue the legitimacy
of the claim or anything like that. It was to show that you're
very soft on Destiny but not others. And you and he apologized.
Idubbbz retracted and
for doing it.
He didn't. He didn't. I believe he would have been very careful
to not retract in a way that made it seem like he was saying
that, but I think he retracted like even doing the stream. The
concept of the stream that he could use that even in the way
he did was something he apologized for. And >> used that
outrageously gross comment as an example of it. But if you're
going after Idubbbz solely because you know you can get a defamation
case win because of Canada's laws not being as protective as
the US is. That's why you don't go after Destiny, then that to
me says that you were just trying to take advantage of those
laws, the lack the lax nature of those laws in Canada to get
revenge on someone that has wronged >> I said from the
be >> I mean you could also just look at his statements,
right? I do believe he has basically said that just in lawyer
fees they'd be bankrupted. Or is that there's no way that's just
commentary on the side. I believe Ethan said that as well, right?
like we want to get into this because even the lawyer's fees
will like be atrocious for them.
>> Beginning that any if people want to go after my children
then you know the rules of engagement have changed >> So
it really feels less about the actual defaming and more about
just being able to continue to like really drive the nail into
Idubbbz which is extremely unnecessary. His own community didn't
agree with him when he did this. He lost members of his community
for this because he was so in the wrong for it. Everyone was
on your side when all of this was unfolding. So really what else
are you even trying to accomplish? He came out of that much worse
and he uh outright apologized for it, admitted how wrong he was
for it and everything like that eventually, which is a significantly
bigger L than like a legal one in the eyes of the internet to
be like that wrong and that much on like the wrong side of like
the drama. All you had to do was just leave it at that. But by
making this lawsuit, you've now made a new issue out of it that
is a concern and can affect other people entirely unrelated to
it. And I'm honestly very surprised why Ethan can't see that
after all of the lawsuits he's been through. Something like this
should be very apparent how it can be used exploitatively against
others even outside of a case of like this extreme degree. Like
Ethan of 10 years ago, I think would absolutely see that. But
right now, I just think after everything that he's been through,
he's just completely clouded by it and can't see that anymore.
But now let's dive into like the concern about how this can affect,
you know, free speech or discourse online because Ethan is talking
about like how he doesn't understand how it could because this
is such an extreme thing that was said that's so gross.
>> It's the cultural norm. It's the principle in the commentary
community that people are defending Ethan doing this. That's
the real thing that affects the norm. It's the norms being affected.
It's not like a legal precedent. It's the precedent of breaking
that principle that hey, everything stays on the internet. It's
all it's all banter. It's all talk on the internet and that's
where you leave it. Right? That's the >> And he's right.
This is a very gross thing that was said. And if Idubbbz was
pressing it as a very legitimate thing and trying to make it
seem like it's true to everyone, that kind of thing, then it
would make a lot more sense to go this kind of route because
that is something like the Snark community was doing with like
some really unhinged behavior. So like that would make sense
to me. But that's not what happened here. And the reason why
this is concerning is
>> I again the h man
oh I I know it's like a tough bullet to
but I just don't believe there's any
real proof at all that the start community was involved in a
e either of the two major incidents. I really don't. And that's
the the sad thing. And I know basically based on like how that
whole narrative has gone online and how evil these people have
been made out to be. Nobody really wants to bite that bullet
and just say, "No, I think I think it's probably actually but
I think it is probably actually heard the snark discord had CPS
skulls as a logo though." It does, but it's basically just calling
it out as it's a justification for all of your bad conduct. Like
I there's a huge difference between talking on the internet and
most people being able to keep it there to actually with somebody
in real life. There is it's like a massive massive massive chasm
between doing these two things.
And I would just want to see some kind of actual
like buyin from from one of these snarkers in Discord in on Reddit
somewhere to do some kind of illegal
to do something some kind of something that goes to the level
of the CPS call directly unless it's out of like a genuine concern.
But I again I think if you discuss this with people you wouldn't
be able to convince them of this genuine concern anyway >> because
let's say Ethan does win this lawsuit here that then opens the
door for other people to come in with less extreme like yes in
this case it is very over the top and gross but defamatory statements
aren't just this extreme level. defamatory statements are very
wide reaching and this being something you can point to like
okay so it worked for Ethan it can probably work for me against
this guy who said this thing that actually damaged my brand and
I've seen the response is kind of split and like in the commentary
community I thought it'd be unanimously you know discouraged
for pretty obvious reasons it has historically always been spit
upon but because it's now against someone people don't like Idubbbz
they're okay with it and even laughing about it which I just
don't really get I don't know how the less >> it's really
it's by the way cuz Nicholas will do this deflection every single
time. Okay, Nicholas loves doing this deflection of well guys,
people have sued each other over content before and it's like
not setting any precedent legally at all. No, it's the precedent
of how it's received within this community within the community
of internet commentators.
What it's being what it's being litig what is being litigated,
sorry, and how it's received. That's the precedent.
You being a fat minstrel show. Okay. A
dancer in this minstrel show is the problem. That's the precedent.
Okay. I just want to call him fat. All right.
That's the president. You not standing on principle is the president.
You are destroying the things that you came up on the internet
defending. That's the problem. Nobody gives a about legal precedent.
At least with regards to this stuff. But I forgot guys. He did
disavow it. Uh, guys, I guess I I guess I I'll give you, you
know, like I I'll give you the disavow that I said I would. I
guess I'll give you the disavow that I said I
Worthless, man. >> Lesson has been learned that when something
gets used against someone you don't like, it doesn't mean it's
only ever going to be used against people you don't like. Once
that can of worms is open, it becomes the wild west and it can
be a problem for everybody. Like making an exception like, "Yeah,
ooh, not good. I've always been really against YouTubers filing,
you know, litigation against other content creators, but since
it's Idubbbz, I'll I'll be okay with it. Which I think is some
pretty silly. I think the internet in its first go around with
this topic pin the tail on the donkey. I think they were correct
with the the take on this topic that being extremely ligious
and going after other content creators and such with defamatory
lawsuits and such is just not very good. It's the same tactics
that have been used from some
shady companies in the past against people online. And it's just
a tactic that used to unanimously leave a sour taste in the mouth
of just normal people online. Oh my god.
Oh my god. Charlie's saying it. Charlie's saying it.
Oh my god. And this is, by the way, after he got the spin from
Ethan. After he got the spin from Harley, Charlie is coming out
and just saying the thing that's obvious. This is and anybody
who's not calling it out like what are they even doing? It's
it's like hidden in there in subtext. Okay. But what Charlie's
actually saying right now is Nicholas Yoro is a
Nicholas Yoro is a spineless
who is dancing for cheesecake and watches. Okay. Embarrassing.
Shameful. You are shameful.
Which is really a mouthful when he says we used to kind of be
against this guys and kind of cuts against everything we used
to stand for. But he is on Nicholas Yorio in subtext through
that whole thing. Aren't you happy that you've got me to translate
for you?
>> So I really don't understand this perspective from commentary
channels to treat this like it's just some kind of hoot and holler
and goofy thing. You know, let's celebrate it point and laugh
when I think it's pretty easy to see how this could potentially
be used as ammunition in some uh less than savory lawsuits going
forward specifically in Canada. Uh it would obviously be like
for Canadian YouTubers, but even still, there's no there's just
it's probably best not to just have more ammunition for some
bad actors to be able to exploit legally. >> The precedent
needs to be set that you destroy your career by doing this. That
you set yourself against every commentator on the internet. Every
commentator, no matter how much they like you or hate you, will
turn on you the second you do this.
That's the precedent that needs to be set. As in you will be
a pariah. Nobody will speak to you. Nobody will talk to you.
They will all tell you have cross crossover with a 100 other
streams, 100 other content creators. And every single one of
them will on you for being the piece of garbage you are. That's
the precedent that needs to be set. Not in a court of law on
YouTube for YouTube content
>> More ammunition. >> Ethan Klein is not a pariah
at all. Klein Hila. No. Wrong. He has a pariah within a very
certain small subset of LA streamers and LA content creators
and outside of that people are generally like I don't really
know
because there are a handful of sweepers who want to prevent nature
from taking its course and trust me the broom's getting too heavy
for Nick. Okay, that broom is way too big for him. It's not going
to happen.
>> For some bad actors to be able to >> All you need
to know to understand that that H3 Ethan Klein is not a pariah
is that Charlie reached out to him before publishing this video
to get his side of the story. Charlie felt like he deserved the
respect of like a a what would you like a request for comment.
Ethan Klein doesn't even deserve that, but Charlie did it. That
tells you everything you need to know about him still having
a reputation. that reputation. He, by the way, he thinks his
reputation is dirt. It's not, but it's about to be. >> Now,
like I said, I did have a conversation with both Idubbbz and
Ethan. And at the end of the conversation with Ethan, he wanted
to prepare a statement because I wasn't shy about letting him
know that the exact way I've talked to him in our conversation
would be how I'm going to talk about it publicly. And since I've
made it clear, I'm not in the business of just leaking private
text messages. He wanted to prepare something that I would share.
And I've done this in the past, like sharing statements from
the people that I cover in stories. So, >> Skulls CPS Skulls
CPS Skulls CPS Skulls CPS CPS Skulls CPS Skulls CPS Skulls Snarkers
Snarkers Snarkers Snarkers Snarkers CPS Skulls CPS Skulls Snarkers
I'll do the same here as well. A snark community fabricated a
lie that his children were crawling around in dog and eating
it. After this, he can no longer tolerate attacks on his children
or attempts to break up his family. Ian was a friend of his.
>> Except unless they come from Destiny. Hold on. I can
no longer tolerate attempts to target my children or attempts
to break up my family unless they happen multiple times from
a certain streamer in Florida. Then I could totally tolerate
it for some reason. Cool, cool, cool. It's almost like it doesn't
it's almost like your kids don't matter. It's almost like it
was never about your kids for many years. He has been to his
house, met his children when he displayed a message on screen
for over an hour stating that he's a that his children carried
a lot more weight than when Destiny said it. Destiny said it
in a Discord chat in passing that was on screen for a few seconds.
And Destiny has never been to his house or met his children,
has zero credibility on the issue, and made it clear that in
passing chat message was never meant to be taken seriously. Ian,
on the other hand, does know his family, has been to his home
and has met his children. And the fact that he exploited that
closeness to forward such a heinous, unforgivable accusation,
forced him into action. To make matters worse, Ian has supported
the call to CPS in his content deputy and openly associates with,
spends time in, and celebrates the Snark community from which
the original CPS call came from. He's pledged to do everything
he can to hold him and anyone else who attempts to harm his family
accountable in whatever way that he can. Because of the context,
he believes that he has a much more viable case against Idubbbz
than Destiny. And that's why he's only suing Destiny. Idubbbz.
Destiny also lives in USA where defamation laws are much harder
to win verse in Canada where Idubbbz lives. These are all the
reasons that he's suing Idubbbz and not Destiny. He's chosen
the legal and most proper way afforded to him that live in countries
that value free speech. A lawsuit for defamation. Defamation
is not protected speech. He does not have an unalienable right
to say that he's his children. He has crossed the line and he's
past the point of caring what Charlie or anyone else thinks and
he will protect his family at all costs. Now, if it wasn't clear,
we didn't exactly see eye to eye on this case here in regards
to this whole lawsuit situation. I believe, as is even stated
in his statement, that he's targeting Idubbbz solely because
the free speech laws in Canada are more lax and it is more viable
that he would win there verse in the U. Yes, I do. Listen,
people will get on Charlie for him repeating every every single
point that he's made in this video four times, but you kind of
got to do that sometimes, right?
You do sometimes got to do that. The normies need to have it
repeated like four or five times for them to remember and and
to get it. So, yes, it is that is because of the Canadian speech
laws. And yes, you do think that that's probably a good indication
that he shouldn't be filing the lawsuit, Charlie. Yes, it feels
very familiar for a tactic that is common with big companies
to financially drain someone that they have a lot of issues with
for a variety of reasons, a whole host of reasons. And in pursuing
this route, it does open a whole host of problems for a lot of
other people and can have far-reaching consequences should it
set some kind of precedent or, you know, set an example for others
to try and follow suit. It is something that I've always advocated
against and there's nothing in all of the streams and evidence
I've seen that indicates that Idubbbz was trying to push this
as a true thing using his previous relationship with Ethan as
a place of credibility to to try and breach to his audience that
this comment is accurate. This is a legitimate claim that actually
needs to be investigated. There was nothing I ever saw that gave
me that indication. It was only ever Destiny made this atrocious
comment that Ethan is not being very upset about and having a
very different energy towards him than the others and it was
a very very very poorly made point using a very gross example
for it which is something Idubbbz openly admits. So anyway, I've
been yapping about this for a long time now. Uh that's really
about it. So yeah. >> Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Now, the funny thing here is is to me it should
be very easy for him to see that quite a few of these things
are lies. Why why wouldn't Charlie have been able to like Google
the Ethan Klein item situation and get like a good explanation,
a solid explanation very quickly on how and why Ethan Klein was
lying? Why does he still think it's like all in the snarkers,
all the things that snarkers did are illegal and terrible? Why
does he think all of these things? Well, I I'm starting to start
to think it might be something to do with this guy right here.
Something to do with this right here. this master broomsman right
here. Okay. Very sad.